the gyro can experience what did you
think about Canelo fighting Sergey
Kovalev how crazy was that he flatlines
Sergey Kovalev at 175 pounds oh goodness
Canelo he's a meta means pound for pound
number one whose resume everyone goes
ooh Budd who I love but Crawford shot
the bud bud and Earl Spence
everyone goes that's pound and water
dude look at who Canelo's has beat men
in different divisions you're talking
about [ __ ] more key guys and he
stopping them in the triple G fights
obviously there's some countries there
but she fights real country for the
first ones very controversial second one
not so much
what's up and delayed his fight yes they
did and he's mad at that he said no more
because apparently people were tired man
especially like east coach did you watch
it
I was out yeah I watched it it was
insane yeah they delayed if you ever
four hours turned that they show him in
the back sitting there like what the
waiting for the end of the UFC fight in
the zone that's just like how about the
zone there that how about the zone plate
do UFC in the arena look at this laughs
way off who wrote that who wrote that
tweet Oh impersonator riot was the sake
let me shot him out it says assume
defense Imperator Ryan the to defend
Twitter it says L LM a Okinawan kovalev
are napping because they gotta wait on
the UFC it's ridiculous like show a
little pride to zone Dana
loved it loved it he was so happy as a
UFC guy I was also like he was so yeah
[ __ ] like what this is who's King you
got can you imagine you imagine Dana
bowing down to the going listen Floyd's
fighting we're not gonna we're gonna
wait for the main the USC doesn't give a
[ __ ] what you got going on how was Nate
Diaz versus Maz Woodall was a special
fight to and the thing about making it
for the bad [ __ ] belt almost
like everybody was like yes everyone why
not you know and now isn't you'll want
to youngjae check gonna fight zhang
wheeling isn't she fighting her for the
belt oh dude that didn't give her that
fight you want to said she wants to
fight for the female bet BMF bout damn
she should fight Jessica and Raj and a
rematch just for 2:48 it's official
Dan's a [ __ ] card so that's the one
they think might be out of sonya and
Yoel Romero so Dan said he didn't want
that fight though termined location Dana
said he did yeah Dana said he didn't
want that fight because yo L losses
Alaska I thought he said he did one no
Dana said he personally Dana didn't
think that was a good fight for Yoel but
think about what else is that what's a
great fight for yo I think it's I mean
for Sonya I think it's a fight for the
division but who else you gonna do you
look at the division there's no one else
well one of the things that Mazda
thought was friends with yo L said I
respect the [ __ ] out of Otto Sonya cuz
he asked for that beast he said the ass
form and that was my point with Andrew
Schultz and like no you don't understand
to build the legend of Izzy him asking
for yo L everybody in the game respects
that you want to fight that [ __ ] in the
monster even dare until Darren till said
anybody but you well yes joking around
after fight he's joking yeah I think
didn't do dare until Whitaker men hmm
that's a great [ __ ] fight well they
talked about doing that on the undercard
of Adesanya you all Romero yes was that
no no no no it was the heart of that was
the undercard of another fight um [ __ ]
What did he say he reached out to some
O'Connor and cowboy that's who it was
he wanted to be on the undercard of
Colorado too soon not happening I don't
know I don't think Witter could be ready
to go by then after again I what is it
what's the date on that January January
war in December dude right but it's six
weeks danto breaks out his red panties
invites robert whittaker to UFC 246
co-main event yeah so that's six weeks
the only thing is robert whittaker got
starch yeah just a couple of months so
you get a hundred twenty days suspension
right well I don't know if he actually
can make that medically no that's what
I'm saying it's it's not gonna happen
it's too soon also I think a fight like
that where you know a guy like a lasagna
just sort of starches you like that that
requires a reset take your time dude
yeah I love what I do too
but maybe not I mean maybe he knows
better than us I don't know nope nope I
don't you think so
I don't think so I'm outside looking in
I'd say
be nice I know dude take your time I
don't think he does take your time but I
would like to see that fight too so
maybe they can make that happen on you
know that March card yeah or maybe yeah
maybe sometime in the future me there
was a great April card as well right
April in the UFC in Brooklyn with Tony
and khabib maybe could be on the
undercard of that'll be great that's
great
[Applause]